okay so today we start Greek
civilization and it is
incredible uh what Greek civilization is
it is the greatest most creative most
significant civilization ever in human
history uh the Greeks really created
western
civilization and not only were the great
what not only were the Greeks the
greatest
civilization there's really not been a
second great gener civilization okay um
so let's think about how incredible the
Greeks were if you look at um
literature the Greeks basically created
literature uh with Homer okay Homer
wrote two books called The Iliad and the
Odyssey and he wrote these books about
3,000 years ago now last year I taught
the great books to the students and we
read many books and by far the favorite
book was zad okay so think about this
how a Greek writer writing 3,000 years
ago for a Greek audience his book Still
resonates Still
impresses uh and still impresses um
students in in China today okay so
that's Homer then you have
Plato philosophy Plato and even
today there are many who consider Plato
the greatest philosophy ER whoever lived
there are many people who read the
Republic by Plato and it and they say
it's
transforms their lives okay it makes
them think very differently about the
world then you have in history a man
named
fiddies if you are a military leader
today you read faciiities okay there are
still many generals today in America in
Russia in Europe who believe reading
forties will help them win
Wars okay so not only the Greeks create
civilization but their Works their books
are still wi they read
today and considered
amazing okay so now the question I have
is how does this happen how were the
Greeks able to create Humanity greatest
civilization in really about 200 years
okay they they really were
not dominant for a long time they really
created all these Works in about 200
years Al together so how is this
possible okay so
um let's go back to last class we talked
about the Bronze Age collapse right and
we talked about how in about
1,00 BCE Greece was
United in a place called mean Greece
okay so basically the means controlled
Greece and Greece was a monarchy and it
was no different from any other place in
the world at this point 1200 BCE the
world was basically the same okay and
then this Society collapsed because of
the branchage collapse and three things
happen okay first of
all
centralization the idea that you had a
unified Society it went away okay so
Greece became chaotic and decentralized
that's the first thing that happened
second thing that
happened um is Greece became
illiterate so Greece Lo the Greeks lost
the abil ability to read and right and
we call this the Dark Ages
so from about a thousand to about 600 BC
but for 400 years the Greeks basically
lost the ability to read and write we
call this the Dark Ages
because we don't have any books or
writing from that period it's completely
dark to us okay so the second thing that
happened the Greeks became illiterate
the third thing that happened
is the the Greeks became poor okay so
before the Greeks traded with the world
it was very prosperous and then because
of R collapse um it started to become
more isolated and became a lot poorer
okay so these are the three major cone
consquences of the Bron AG collapse in
Greece it became decentralized it became
illiterate it became poor and the
amazing thing is it's because of these
three things that Greece became the most
creative civilization in the world okay
so remember this it it is because of the
destruction of old Greece it's because
Greece became chaotic illiterate and
poor that Greece
eventually became the most civiliz the
greatest civilization in the world okay
so let me explain how this happened okay
so there are three major reasons why
Greek cation became dominant the first
reason is the
polus the poll is um it's hard for us to
translate it we usually translate it as
city state
okay a city
state um and this where where we get the
word politics but really um what it
means is
community okay
community and the idea of the Pol is is
a community of people who discuss
politics together how how to best run
the town okay and because of this chaos
there were thousands of policies around
Greece of about a thousand people each
okay so it's a very small
community and this became the main
political structure of Greek society
okay so the polus is one factor second
factor that happened
is the
alphabet so after the Greeks became
illiterate they had to relearn literacy
okay they had to relearn how to read and
write in the process they adopted a new
writing system
called the
alphabet okay which forever transformed
the
society the last thing is
Homer Homer was a poet who introduced to
the Greeks a new way of Imagining the
world okay so these are the three major
factors that led to the rise of Greek
civilization and if you look at each
factor okay so the poll is was a
political
Revolution it's forever
transformed um Society okay the alphabet
was a
language Revolution it forever
transformed the way people communicated
with each other and Homer was really an
intellectual Revolution it forever
transformed how Greeks saw and imagin
the world around them okay
so let's go over each of these
revolutions one by one okay so the
polus there were three things about the
polus
that um allow for Innovation creativity
in Greece okay the first thing about the
Polish was competition
okay these Poes were all spread out and
they were all competing against each
other for resources they were constantly
at war with each other that allowed for
massive Innovation
okay and again remember there's no
centralized Authority now that's the
first thing second thing is
diversity so if you look at the map of
Greece Greece
has very diverse Geography okay it has
um um Farmland has mountains has Plains
it has Coastal land okay and depending
on where you
were geographically in Greece you
develop a different economy and culture
and Society based on the Geography okay
does that make sense and so you had a
lot of
diversity and the last Factor was the
idea of
democracy okay so Greek
civilization uh introduce the idea of
democracy or the modern sense of
democracy to us and the reason why is at
this time Greece was very
poor okay if you're very poor you need
everyone to participate and work hard
especially in battles against other
polies so the rule was you could be rich
or poor but if you fought for us you had
the right to speak
okay you could be the leader of this
polus and you have the right to speak
but if you you could be the poorest
person in this polish and you still had
the right to speak because everyone had
a responsibility to defend the polus
okay so this introduced the idea of
democracy and what this meant was that
everyone basically had to
participate
politically so you could be farmer but
you still have to think about the
political life and you still had a
responsibility to speak up in front of
your peers okay and this is where we get
the idea of polus
from and this was a major driver of
innovation in
Greece okay so does this make sense guys
the
Polish any questions so far before I
move
on okay so one of the major inov ations
of AP polis was the introduction of the
alphabet into Greek society okay so um
let me explain the development of
writing systems over time to you okay
and this this can be comp be be a bit
complicated um so make sure you're
following along if if I'm seeing
something unclear to you make sure you
interrupt and ask me questions okay all
right so writing was first developed in
Europe uh in Western Society in Egypt
and in
Samaria and they did so to solve an
economic problem okay so these societies
were very wealthy and they needed people
uh Farmers to help them build roads and
build irrigation networks and build
temples okay to do so I need to pay
these workers right so writing system
became a contract
all right a contract so basically um the
wunning system at first was a pictogram
a
pictograph that serve the function of a
contract so for example if I do
this okay two
people okay so what this is saying is if
you work for me I promise to give two
people two bushes of wheat okay and so
when you have this you can then give it
to me and I have to give you the wheat
does that make sense so they first start
as pictograms and what they recognize is
hey we can just have this as
symbols right so maybe just two faces
and then two v's and this could
represent the same thing because
everyone understood what it meant so you
went to symbolism that's the next
step all right but then what they
recognize is hey
these symbols can also represent
ideas okay so here's an example all
right so you have maybe a sun and a moon
right okay sun and moon you can they can
represent the sun and the moon but if
you put them together okay Sun and the
Moon you get the concept of
day right so now you have a concept an
idea day okay we call this an idiogram
and guess what guys
Chinese is an idiogram language does
that make sense okay and then as they
continue developing writing they they
recognized that you know what it would
be a lot easier for us to communicate if
these idiograms represented syllables
and sounds
instead okay so rather than representing
ideas let's get them to represent sounds
so for example this is um sun right and
this is
Moon well now if we if we do
this it becomes Moon Sun right which is
English word for Monsoon which means
storm okay so now this it this tells us
to read it as Monsoon
okay and then the final the final recog
recognition is guess what we can
actually just have the sound represent a
consonant okay the simplest sound and
this would be an M this would be an S so
if I write something like this it now
becomes SM or
sum okay and we call
this the
alphabet does it make sense okay so this
is the development of writing
and the reason why we do this is um with
each Innovation each development we're
allowed more
flexibility in our language to
communicate our
ideas does it make sense guys okay so
now with the
alphabet something remarkable has
happened before it before um these
develop these different stages of
writing required a professional class of
people to manage the writing system okay
we call these scribes right scribes the
reason why is that writing is not
speaking speaking is one language but
writing is a different language this is
true for Chinese right what was true
back then as well so to learn to read
and write you had to have professional
scribes to do so because it was such a
complicated task
okay does that make
sense all
right but now with the alphabet writing
can become
speaking and this marked a
incredible
revolution in human thought and the
capacity to think okay so let me explain
why before the invention of writing we
lived in an oracle
culture in or culture okay in or culture
means we don't write we just speak to
each other all right now now we live in
a writing culture a literary culture
where we don't actually speak to each
other we mainly just write to each other
okay so mainly through email or texting
okay now there are certain advantages to
both
cultures with oral culture the first
major advantage is
it's very
emotional okay when I'm speaking to you
I'm trying to get you excited I'm trying
to get you to pay attention so I'm
trying to think about how to Rouse your
emotions so so oral culture it's very
emotional Focus that's the first major
advantage second major advantage is it's
very Innovative and
open and what this means is I can create
words when I speak right I can
sayak okay that means nothing okay but I
can create it and when we're speaking
you can figure out what I mean so when
I'm speaking I can create all these
different words so so there's room for
Innovation and Imagination in oral
culture does that make sense Okay the
third thing
is the thing about oral culture is it
forces everyone to have a really strong
memory the reason why is when I speak I
C I have to remember my speech right and
then you have to remember my speech in
order to respond to my speech and these
speeches go on for like hours and hours
so back then during or culture everyone
had a photographic
memory okay does that make sense so back
then they were a lot smarter than we are
today and it's the same as remember
during the hunter gatherer stage right
when we were out in the field guess what
guys they were a lot stronger faster and
healthier than we are today because
today all we do is sit
around right does that make sense so
back then they were a lot smarter than
us so these are the three major
advantages of em of or culture it's very
emotional language it's very Innovative
and it forces you to have a really
strong memory okay but there's also a
lot of advantages to writing culture as
well that or culture doesn't have so for
example the first major advantage is
rather than emotional it has to be
logical right it has to make sense by
itself I can't trick you with rhetoric
all right I have to use reason and logic
to persuade you because you can read it
at your own time okay so that's a first
major advantage second major advantage
is it's very
disciplined okay meaning okay I can't
make up words I have to use words we we
are okay the third major
advantage um
is even though it decreases my memory it
stores up brain space for me to think
deeply about the argument for me to
reflect on your argument and find
logical problems in your argument okay
does that make sense all right so we are
basically before they were in oral
culture
um and that had certain
advantages now we are in a liter culture
and we've lost the oral culture
okay but when the Greeks discovered the
alphabet what happened was they combined
the advantage of both cultures okay they
were most of the time they were speaking
they were living in a roal culture but
they also had the opportunity to write
down their thoughts which allowed them
the advantages of the litter culture to
have a more disciplined focused logical
mind okay does that make
sense and this marked an incredible
Revolution the capacity for human beings
to
think okay any questions so
far okay this is very complicated
concept I I I want to make sure you're
following along okay any questions about
what I just said before I move on
all right now let's move on to Homer
okay
homer so we discussed the polus and how
it is a new political structure which
allows for freedom and democracy we
discussed the alphabet which marks a
revolution in our capacity to
think okay now it comes along Homer and
Homer is a poet
and back then there were many poets who
went around and and told stories about
the world okay Legends
mythologies and the very best poets are
usually hired by Kings okay rich people
because Kings need poets to solve three
problems okay Kings usually hire poets
to solve three problems the first
problem
is legitimate
Authority okay what this means is you
have to answer the question if you're
King why are you king now we know that
most Kings get power by killing a lot of
people okay that's how they become king
by fighting Wars and by winning wars so
when they become king they need to clean
up their image okay they need to legit
legitimize their
Authority so what they tell people is
usually what why why am I
King why
exactly God chose me and how do I prove
God chose
me how do I prove
that because there's a poet who sings a
beautiful song about me and this song
can only come from divine
inspiration right the poet is a vessel
for
divine um message mes right does that
make sense this poem this song is so
beautiful it must be divine and if this
Divine song is saying I am the I am born
of a God the gods want me to become king
then I must be divine myself doesn't
make sense okay so that's the first
major function of poets in these Society
to legitimate legitimize Authority
second function is to create a cultural
identity
so you know in China you have books like
sang okay Ro Romans are three kingdoms
you have the Bible all these literary
Works their function is to create a
common cultural identity okay it tells
us what it means to be
Chinese does that make sense because
then you unify the people who then obey
the king who unifies them right that's
the second function the third
function is the idea of culture
differentiation to know who you are you
must also know who you are not we're
Chinese so therefore we are not Japanese
we're not Korean we're not American okay
doesn't make sense so most literary
works that we
have were sponsored by leaders Kings to
to to solve these three problems okay so
uh in the future we will read uh the
inad uh which is what the Romans had
will read the Bible
okay um in China you have like um the
Romans of the three kingdom and all
these literary Works were
designed to serve the
powers that exist at that time okay does
that make sense the problem with Homer
is when he was around and we don't know
actually when he was live maybe about 6
uh 800 to 600 BC okay around then we
don't know actually know okay but there
was no King there's no one to pay him
therefore he could only make his living
by appealing
to the people around him okay he had to
appeal to orer
people and so the question then is if
you're a poet how do you get H people
who are poor to pay you
money why would they want to pay you to
sing songs for them okay well there are
three
reasons the first
is just
entertainment today we listen to songs
we go to movies well back
then their entertainment their source of
entertainment was to pay people like
Homer to sing songs to them okay
that was that was what they were thought
was fun to do that was their source of
entertainment second reason is
education so remember that back then
Greece was poor they didn't have schools
but because of the Pol system they had
to speak in front of their peers so how
did you learn to speak well well you
learn you do so by imitating people who
do speak well who are usually poets
right so you listen to Homer speak and
give speeches you can imitate him and
copy what he does to make your own
speech in front of your peers okay so
second reason is educational basically
Homer was a teacher as well as a
poet okay now the third
reason and what made Homer special is
what we call
edification edification
edification means to be a better you to
be a higher you
okay
and
edification the way that Homer
accomplish
edification is by changing the way that
you saw the world around you the way you
felt about the world the way you
imagined the world okay
so let me explain how he did so but
first of all before before I continue
are there any questions about this so
far anything anything you are not clear
about any anything I've said that you
are not clear about or you're confused
by before I
continue okay so Homer was a poet who
told stories and the the most popular
story at that time was something called
the children
War so the main story of the children
war is this okay so there was a Greek
goddess named Nemesis and Nemesis likes
to create problems she's always thinking
of ways to get the gods to fight against
each other so one day she creates this
apple it's a golden apple and the golden
apple says to the most beautiful goddess
in the world okay it doesn't say who it
just says to the most beautiful goddess
in the world
and then she just puts it on Mount
Olympus for the gods to find three
goddesses find this apple and they fight
over it okay the first goddess is Hera
who is the um Queen God okay second
goddess is Athena who is the goddess of
wisdom the third goddess is apod who is
the goddess of love they're fighting
over this apple all the time and they're
creating a huge
Ruckus and so the king God Zeus gets
tired of all their fighting and he finds
a human stupid enough to be the judge
okay so this human uh his name is
Paris his job is to pick who is the most
beautiful goddess in the universe okay
is it gonna be Hera apina or Aphrodite
okay and again he's stupid enough to
want to piss off two goddesses
right so when he's making his decision
all the goddesses try to bribe Paris
Paris says to
Paris Paris if you pick me I will give
you your own kingdom I will make you
king of the world Paris is like oh
that's that's pretty good Athena says to
Paris I will make you the wisest man in
the world I will give you all the
knowledge of the world and Paris is like
oh that's pretty good and then after
after he says hey I will give you the
most beautiful woman in the world to
marry and then is like I want that okay
and so par but the problem is the most
beautiful woman in the world is Helen
queen of Sparta she's a Greek who's
married to a Greek king Paris steals
Helen takes her back to Troy and then
the Greeks get angry and they raise this
huge Army and for 10 years they attack
Troy which is a walled City okay and the
war ends when a Greek General named o
disas he comes up with this idea called
The Wooden horse Okay so the Greeks
pretend they give up they they're going
to go home because they're homesick and
and as a present uh to the Trojans they
leave behind a wooden horse the Trojans
take the wooden horse into the city at
night the Greeks jump out of the wooden
horse open the gates and the children
are slaughtered okay and this is the
story of the uh children War and the
Greeks love the story because it's
really the Greeks being Heroes right the
Greeks have this great Victory people
love to win battles what's amazing about
Homer story okay it's called The Iliad
and we will read this next
semester that there are three things
that Homer does in The Iliad that's
really never been done before okay and
so with the ilad we have the invention
of literature the first
thing that Homer
does
is rather than telling the story from
the Greek side he tells the story from
both the Greek and Trojan side in fact
when you read thead you'll discover that
the Trojans are actually more heroic
more courageous and more Brave than the
Greeks okay that's pretty amazing and by
switching perspective
a new idea comes into being that never
really existed before and we call this
idea
empathy okay empathy the ability to see
the world from the perspective of other
people and before in human civilization
this didn't really exist before okay but
Homer creates this for the
ilad the second thing that is new and
unique to the ilad is human
psychology so for the first time Homer
discusses what
motivates the
characters in the in in in the ilad okay
why are you fighting this war and so the
story is between two individuals
Achilles and King prome
okay so Achilles is The Greatest Warrior
of the Greeks prum is the king of the
Trojans and they hate hate each other
okay because they're enemies Achilles is
trying to kill pram Prime is trying to
defend his family and his home so um the
ilot starts like this
Achilles at the beginning gets in a
fight with egam Manon who is the king of
the Greeks okay they get in a fight and
they curse each other and achilles says
you're your dog eanon I'm never going to
fight for you again and aanon the King
says I don't need you man so Achilles
refuses to fight okay the problem is
Achilles is The Greatest Warrior of the
Greeks and the
Trojans um led by Hector who is a son of
Priam he sees an opportunity because
Achilles refuses to fight and Hector
leads the children Army out of Troy and
they're destroying the Greeks
and the Trojans are about to crush the
Greek army so the Greek generals say to
Egon could you please beg Achilles to
return to the
battlefield and they go and they talk to
Achilles and achilles basically says
screw off I'm not helping you guys okay
his friend
Petrus okay Petrus is basically like his
younger brother he feels sorry for the
Greeks so he pretends to be Achilles and
goes off to battle against Hector Hector
kills Petras and this angers Achilles
okay Achilles is so angry that he jumps
into the battle and he kills Hector once
he kills Hector he does something very
odd okay usually when you kill someone's
body you return that body to your enemy
for a ransom because the belief back
then is only if you bury your dead can
the dead find peace in the in the after
World
okay but Achilles is so angry at Hector
that he's
torturing Hector's body which is
torturing
prium but even after Achilles does
this he can't sleep and he feels
tremendous sadness even though he's
Avenged the death of fas and the reason
why is in his heart Achilles
knows he was the one responsible for
killing Petrus right because if he
didn't get into the stupid fight with ag
Manon and if he did not refuse the
Greeks when they requested help and
petas wouldn't have died so it's because
achillus was so stubborn and so proud
that his friend petas died so he feels
tremendous guilt for what happened and
his guilt turns into an intense hatred
for Hector that's why he's torturing
Hector's
body then what happens is pram King pram
who can't sleep either because his son
is being tortured okay his son is dead
but his soul is still being tortured by
Achilles he sneaks into Achilles tent
okay and he's right behind Achilles
while ailles is talking to his generals
and at this point remember Achilles
doesn't see him he's standing behind
Achilles he could take his knife and
stab Achilles in the neck right and
that's what most people would do but
Prim doesn't do that Prime instead
kneels down and kisses the hand of
Achilles which forces
Achilles to be in awe of this king who
has knelt down before him and he admires
PR's
courage and love for his son so much
that he feels tremendous shame and
remorse for what he's done to Hector and
he returns Hector's body to prum as
compensation and that's how the ilad
ends okay the main message of the ilad
is it's not war that creates
civilization it is love that creates
civilization it is Prime's love for
Hector that gives him the courage to
defeat
Achilles in battle and in this defeat
Achilles becomes a better person because
he's able to forgive himself and he's is
able to do what is right and just and
return um Hector to his father okay
that's the that's the ilc as as you can
imagine this is
extremely complicated
psychology and it forces you to think
deeply about who we are as
humans
okay okay does that make sense the third
thing that is shocking about daad is the
use of
metaphors so what are metaphors
metaphors are connections between things
that were unseen okay so for example if
I say the
sky is a
snail you're like oh I didn't know that
okay do you understand that's what a
metaphor is a metaphor is connecting two
things that before were not connected if
you think about it what is is a new
thought and there are lots of metaphors
in the ilad okay so
essentially metaphors teach you how to
think okay they are the tools for
thought so these are the three distinct
characteristics of the ilad that make it
um unique in the world okay it's
switching perspectives all the time
which creates empathy
right it talks about human psychology
all the time which creates
imagination and it uses metaphors which
enables you to think much more deeply
about the world okay if you put these
three things together what this
is ultimately
is a
theory of
human okay it's a theory of what it
means to be a human being before we
thought human beings thought over land
they thought over uh woman like Helen
okay they struggle for power what Homer
is saying is what it means to be a human
is someone who has empathy
imagination
and the willingness to think
okay only if you're willing to see feel
and think are you
human this is a new Theory
of
human that becomes the basis for Greek
civilization and that's why the Greeks
believe the founder of the Civ
civilization was not a general it was
not a king it was a poet named
Homer okay and it's because of the ilad
that they all read and
memorized and they could recite okay
because again this is an oral culture
where you're trained to have a very
strong memory and because they memorize
the Iliad it forever
transform them
as humans okay this is a new theory of
what it means to be human and this
becomes the basis for Greek civilization
which then becomes the basis for western
civilization and it's because of these
three reasons the
polus um the alphabet and Homer that
we have W civilization as we know it
today okay any questions so
far any questions so far
guys all right now I'm going to spend
some time and discuss okay why is Greek
civilization different from Chinese
civilization okay and this will help you
better understand um Western
Civilization so the first question is
why is it the Greeks developed alphabet
okay the alphabet and the Chinese did
not develop the
alphabet okay the answer is this the
answer is
um
Greece was not an isolated culture okay
so the people who actually developed the
alphabet were the
Egyptians okay
Egyptians and the reason why is egyp was
constantly in contact and communication
with many different societies and
cultures including the samarians and the
Greeks and they could adopt new
practices to advance their
language okay so it was a Greeks it was
Egyptians who develop um the
alphabet um the Phoenicians were
traitors and the the phans connected the
Egyptian culture to everyone else okay
so it's the Phoenicians who brought the
alphabet to the Greeks who because they
became illiterate were looking for a new
language system okay does that make
sense that's why that's how the Greeks
got the alphabet again the question is
why didn't China develop the alphabet
and the answer is this China for most of
its history was isolated from the rest
of the
world but not only was China isolated
but it was stable for most of its
history because for most of China's
history China was running by a class of
people called scholar officials right
confusion
Scholars what was their power what what
was their secret power it was the
ability to read and write that's what
differentiate them from everyone else
right that's what made them
indispensable to the emperor that's why
they were so powerful and so when you
have a monopoly over literacy you don't
want to give it up you want to increase
it and the way they did so is by
creating a new language call classical
Chinese literally Chinese okay does that
make sense that's why there was this
Divergence between Greece and China at
this
time because China the PO literacy was
monopolized by an elite who benefited
from from this Monopoly and therefore
they made this Monopoly much more
effective by introducing a new language
called classical Chinese that only they
could
Master okay does that make sense guys
EXC
me
because um the schull officials they
were in charge of bureaucracy right if
you're if you're running a bureaucracy
you need the ability to read and write
you need the ability to tr to to
basically um transport information from
one place to to the next right that's
through reading and writing through
literacy
doesn't make sense so only they could
become
bureaucrats
okay so does that make sense okay any
more
questions okay second question
is why is it the Greeks had Homer and
the Chinese we Chinese we never had
Homer okay and again the problem are the
scholar officials um if you look at
confusion thought
um there's a hierarchy in confusion
thought in confusion thought right at
the very top are scholar officials
they're the most virtuous they they're
the most well educated the most
cultivated okay they're the best people
next to the below the SCH officials are
uh the farmers and The Artisans right
because they produce wealth for society
below them are the
merchants right and then at the very
bottom are
who the
artists right The
Poets now guess what guys in Greece this
was the complete opposite they placed
Homer at the very top of the society
everyone wanted to be a poet like Homer
okay so when Plato was running the
Republic he was trying to become Homer
he was trying to become a teacher of
civilization an in an inspirer of
civilization ation okay a big G of
civilization that's what Plato wanted
but guess what forties when he wrote the
pipan war he was trying to do the same
thing he was trying to inspire
civilization he was trying to inspire
new
ideas because they all wanted to become
Homer okay because they all knew Homer
was the father of civilization and they
wanted to continue his
legacy and that's what made the Greeks
unique in human history because only the
society put poets first and foremost at
the top and no other Society did so okay
in China was the complete opposite
because if you're a small official what
you're most afraid of is independent
thinking okay so
censorship
censorship was their main role okay
controlling how people thought through
censorship and that's why China never
really produced a homer or a great
thinker
okay doesn't make sense right but and so
this is going to be strange but it's
only because Greece got destroyed by the
at the at the end of the Bronze
Age it became decentralized it lived in
poor that they could then become a great
civilization it was only through
destruction that they could have the
polis the alphabet and Homer okay and
that's the main message of human history
it's through destruction that we have
Innovation and it's only through this
process that human beings are able to
rejuvenate the society okay does that
make sense any
questions was this clear to you
guys okay so we'll continue the Greeks
okay